eh bien bon
à tous et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
trois théories et accessoirement la
dernière vidéo de l'année 2020 ça va
commencer à devenir un petit rituel 2017
on finissait sur du star wars 2018
pareil en 2019
il y avait toute la hype endgame mais
2020 on re termine encore avec star wars
et en même temps quelle série
mandaloriennes est vraiment génial ça
c'est un vrai kif
je ne vais pas m'éterniser sur l'intro
sachets évidemment comme d'hab que ces
théories proviennent de moi de mes
inspirations de mes idées et c'est tout
et 100% subjectif je vous invite quant à
vous à me partager vos opinions en
commentaire car vous avez toujours de
belles choses à dire donc je compte sur
vous let's go entamons les théories ah
oui alors je rallume la caméra parce que
j'ai oublié de vous dire tout simplement
que cette vidéo va spoil mandaloriennes
saison 2 évidemment et bats la théorie
de spoil aura également la série rebels
donc voilà vous êtes prévenus allez on
entame
[Musique]
quelque chose m'interpelle beaucoup
concernant mof guy des hommes pour que
vous compreniez bien la chose guider
homme a agi pour l' empire pendant de
nombreuses années jusqu'à devenir mof
pendant la période où se déroule la
série mandaloriens 1,9
c'est une sorte de général de l' empire
un gouverneur et là où c'est encore plus
intrigant et que guy dionne en plus de
s'intéresser à gros goût ou encore la
force
il s'active sur un secteur très précis
pour l' empire les mandaloriens ce n'est
pas dit explicitement car guider on
s'intéresse avant tout à gros goût et le
fait que mando le protège soit un
concours de circonstances une rencontre
fortuite mais guidé homme est devenu mof
pendant la grande purge mandaloriennes
et il en ressort avec le sabre noir
sabres qui est le symbole de réunions
des mandaloriens larmes du leader et
tout ce qui va avec guide et on le sait
très bien
au point même qu'il forcera le combat
contre jean jouines dans le but de soi
le battre et donc tout va bien dans ce
cas soit il perd mais reste quand même
vainqueur au fond carbo catane n'aura
pas eu son combat légitime face à lui et
donc ne pourra pas récupérer le sabre et
réunira les mandaloriens
pour en arriver à la saison 3 guides et
on est toujours vivant et n'en a pas
fini avec la série
il est même dit que son rôle sera encore
plus important et cela semble logique
après avoir prouvé sa valeur à l' empire
en détrônant beau catane et réduit à
néant le peuple mandaloriens 10 des
hommes dont l'étymologie signifie grand
guerrier est officiellement le leader
des mandaloriens avec son sabre noir
jusqu'à que jean jouines le battent en
duel
à la manière de gars saxon et si guy des
hommes était un ancien mandaloriens qui
se seraient tournés vers l' empire
ce n'est clairement pas impossible cela
s'est déjà produit et on connaît 10 mhz
il aime reprendre des concepts d'oeuvre
secondaire ou même des oeuvres canon
mais moins populaire pour l'adapter dans
du live action dans une logique
scénaristique cela permettrait de lier
véritablement c'est antagonistes à dean
jarry puisque gros goût naissance et
plus faire partie de l'histoire son arc
s'est terminée quand l'udc l'a emmené
avec lui et en partant de cette idée
cela pourrait expliquer bien des choses
notamment son rôle dans la saison 3 déjà
le fait qu'il soit très voire trop au
courant des coutumes mandaloriennes des
croyances des clans etc
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas du
tout anodin il est même d'ailleurs très
surpris que mando le laisse en vie après
l'avoir vaincue et souhaite en tirer des
avantages des avantages qui seront que
hbo catane dans sa quête de réunir les
mandaloriens et restaurer mandalore
pourrait amener un guide et eaunes
prisonniers comme trophée au peuple
mandaloriens pour prouver son rang et sa
légitimité
sauf que guy dionne se servirait de sa
survie pour raconter la véritable
histoire l'histoire qu'un nouveau clan
de 2
le clan me dhorne composé d'un
mandaloriens du nom de jean jouines et
d'un enfant de la force aurait vaincu le
nouveau détenteur
sabre noir dans un combat légitime et
que hbo catane aurait une fois de plus
échoué là où mando aurait réussi un acte
qui diviserait encore une fois le peuple
mandaloriens car les adeptes de beaux
catane serait une fois de plus déçu de
sa défaite et qu'un inconnu qui ne
souhaitent pas gouverner auraient
l'obligation de devenir le nouveau
dirigeant légitime du peuple un inconnu
qui en plus de ça fait parti d'un culte
mandaloriens archaïque et qui n'est plus
suivie par la majorité
un coup politique orchestrée par guy des
hommes qui dans une division ultime
pourrait tirer profit voire faire couler
boka tan définitivement
[Musique]
là où star wars tire sa force c'est
grâce à sa grande liberté une liberté
qui peut jouer de mauvais tours par
moments mais star wars n'est pas
chronologique c'est une saga avec une
histoire où plusieurs trous sont à
combler suite à la fin de star wars
rebels nous sommes postes en dehors et
même après la bataille de jack ou
lempire est tombé palpatine et vador ont
été vaincus l'ère de la nouvelle
république arrive à grands pas c'est
alors que dans cette fin ahsoka refait
son apparition après avoir été sauvé par
ezra dans le monde entre les mondes
munis d'une carte blanche cette dernière
se présentera devant sabine pour
réaliser l'ultime quête des deux
protagonistes
les derniers mots prononcés par izraa
ahsoka débrouille toi pour me retrouver
et dans une logique de récit linéaire
automatiquement l'idée kassoka rencontre
d'inge arin après avoir fait son retour
face à sabine devient évident sauf que
non on ne sait pas combien de temps
s'est passé avant kassoka se présente
devant sabine pour aller rechercher et
aux rats et ce trône possible dit que
c'est possible
il se pourrait donc que le chapitre xiii
demande à laurianne se soient déroulés
avant la scène de fin de rebels
hélas cela prend sens voir cela apporte
presque des révélations pour la suite
des événements il est clair que toute
cette histoire sera certainement
développer dans la série dédiée à ahsoka
et nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
mais l'histoire d'ahsoka durera dans
l'ère du mandaloriens la même époque la
même continuité et il se pourrait qu'il
y ait plus de liens qu'on ne le croit
seul sur malachor ahsoka a dû survivre
et trouver un moyen de revenir de cette
planète
de par la connaissance de beaux catane
sur la localisation de l'ex jedi il
semble logique d'interpréter l'idée
qu'après son sauvetage
ahsoka soit allé vers mende alors pour
retrouver cet ancien allié beau catane
qui depuis a fait la connaissance de
l'escadron phoenix et notamment le
groupe d sera bridgeurs ce serait elle
qui aurait mis au courant à saucats de
la situation de ce qu'il s'est passé sur
l'eau talent la disparition de tron et
ezra etc
dans sa quête pour retrouver aux rats
ahsoka aurait dirigé ses recherches vers
le grand amiral trône dans une logique
de protection des droits puisque
normalement si on trouve tron on trouve
les ans et c'est là que cela devient
pertinent ahsoka bas la magistrate et il
lui sous traitent les informations sur
la localisation de tron encore une fois
impossible de situer exactement la fin
de rebels
il est possible qu'à soca et déjà
retrouver trône voir izra à ce moment là
mais pourquoi être venu chercher sabine
pour repartir avec elle c'est là la
liaison possible avec mamda lauriane de
par sa valeur et sa légitimité grâce à
sa victoire contre le clan saxon ahsoka
auraient pu être envoyés par hbo catane
sur l'eau talent dans l'optique de
réunir le peuple mandaloriens et appuyer
la légitimité perdue de beaux catane à
qui elle avait donné le sabre ce serait
le croisement des chemins notamment par
rapport à la théorie
c'est dante par rapport à tignes jarry
ahsoka aurait pu potentiellement se
servir de lui pour retrouver un signe
des grades grâce à l'appel de gros goût
sûr title et là où se croisent m'en
serais encore plus intéressant est que
sabine est resté sur l'eau talent
jusqu'à l'arrivée d'ahsoka ce qui
signifie qu'elle n'a pas forcément eu
connaissance de la purge mandaloriennes
orchestrée par l' empire
ce qui signifie que peut-être que le
clan wren a été décimée sous le
commandement de beaux catane et ou
dispersées à travers la galaxie une
lourde défaite qui pourrait enragé
sabine et la confronter à baud catane
accompagné de jean jouines d'inge arts
ina qui ne partagent pas du tout le même
culte que sabine une dissonance qui
pourrait opposer les deux personnages
dans une première approche de croisement
de chemins permettrait en tout cas de
mêler les histoires et de légitimer
encore plus la cohérence de l'univers
star wars
après star wars 6 avec pourquoi pas la
possible réapparition de jean jouines
dans la propre série d'assauts cas mais
bon je commence à m'en bats les un peu
il est vrai je garde néanmoins la grande
possibilité de voir sabine demande à
l'organe est certainement dans la série
d'assauts cas
[Musique]
pour terminer cette vidéo il est temps
de parler d'une théorie qui a forcément
traverser votre pensée mais dont je
trouve l'importance la pertinence
capitale le rôle de baby yoda pour l'
empire était de récupérer son sens ces
gènes bref ce qui compose gros vous qui
êtes un utilisateur de la force qui
semble puissante chez et cette quête
manoeuvré par m'offre guide et on sera
finalement réussit cinq ans après la
bataille d'endor et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant
noc est un stream caste une forme de vie
artificielle construite grâce à diverses
méthodes scientifiques il n'est pas nice
noc
il est devenu une forme de vie qui sera
indépendante et qui sera manier la force
manipulé dans l'ombre par palpatine
et c'est là où ça coule de source
puisque les jedi ne courent plus les
rues en cette période
ahsoka est inconnu au bataillon pour le
premier ordre ne se définit plus comme
une jedi voire même considéré morte par
beaucoup ezra a disparu et personne ne
l'a jamais encore retrouvé et puis il
nous reste luke et leia les ennemis
directe du premier ordre qui savent se
défendre donc voilà gros goût est
l'unique moyen pour palpatine de créer
des êtres sensibles à la force pour le
gros problème est que la post au logis
est hyper fou on ne sait pas quand snk a
été créé on ne sait pas où en es
palpatine
cinq ans après sa défaite si son plan
sur hexagoal est déjà en route ou non
etc
et il existe même une incohérence
puisque l'udc promet à dean charyn
d'entrée ni gros goût et et mandat
lauriane se déroule cinq ans après la
bataille d'endor sauf qu'il a commencé
son académie jedi grâce ou à cause de
ben solo onze ans après la bataille
d'endor puis d'autres élèves sont
arrivés par la suite
ben est normalement le premier élève de
l'udc est la raison de son acabit si je
vous parle de ça c'est pour vous montrer
la complexité de la chose parce que tout
est flou taux n'est pas vraiment défini
encore donc dans l'idée nous pouvons
manipuler les éléments de l'histoire à
notre guise car rien n'est véritablement
établie dans cette période
bien évidemment ces des informations me
manque n'hésitez pas à me le préciser en
commentaire donc voilà dans une certaine
cohérence les informations génétiques de
gros bobos ont largement pu servir à la
création de snow surtout de vie des
hommes est un mof un titre qui lui a
forcément été conférée par quelqu'un un
quelqu'un qui certainement mettrai en
place les plans du retour de palpatine
orchestrée par le seigneur si lui-même
guide et hommes ne seraient pas au
courant mais il a trouvé la clé de
l'avènement du premier ordre qui
dominera la galaxie à peu près 25 ans
plus tard
mais qu'en est il du destin de gros goût
outre l'incohérence de l'udc
il se peut qu'on trouve certaines
explications nous savons que gros goût a
connu l'ordre jedi
il fut même entraîné par des maîtres
jedi et là ça coince pour l'udc
si nous voulons qu ainsi des mandats
lauriane et la posologie cela signifie
que l'udc n'a pas encore l'idée de créer
une académie jedi est pire que ça encore
l'histoire de gros goût ne coïncide pas
avec la mentalité actuelle de l'udc dans
la post au logis luc nous montre qu'il
n'a formé que des nouveaux élèves des
enfants qui n'ont pas connu l'histoire
et qui sont nés après l' empire luc à
cacher l'histoire de sa famille akai
lorraine il souhaitait créer de
nouvelles bases solides et gros go va
totalement à l'encontre de cette
démarche lui qui a peur qui cache ses
pouvoirs pour survivre et qui a connu la
période de crise de l'ordre jedi
il se pourrait donc qu'à la manière
d'obi wan avec la naissance du fils
d'anakin l'udc est cachée gros go sur
une planète et l'aurait entraînée aux
arts jedi à l'abri de tous un
entraînement qui lui aurait fait émerger
l'idée de former d'autres apprentis une
idée qui sera poussé par l'existence de
son neveu dans qui coule le sang des
skywalker dans une logique scénaristique
cela expliquerait pourquoi gros goût est
absent de la post au logis et surtout
pourquoi instaurer un nouveau personnage
prêt à devenir un jedi dans
mandaloriennes alors qu'il est condamné
à mourir de la main de kayes lorraine
lors de sa rébellion
ce serait dommage est un petit peu idiot
non dans tous les cas on reverra très
certainement gros goût 1
pour qui sait peut-être aurons-nous un
saut dans le temps ou mando et gros goût
se reverront bien des années plus tard
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout pour ceux qui sont encore
là
l'avenir de star wars commence à bien
s'écrire avec mandat lauriane je vois
vraiment un futur radieux
évidemment on aura l'occasion de
reparler de tout ça de cette série
quémanda lauriane des autres séries qui
ont été annoncés il ya vraiment plein de
choses autour de star wars à qui
deviennent vraiment incroyable donc
j'espérais revenir avec notamment le
mystère des draps et de thrawn
franchement c'est quelque chose qui me
m'intéresse particulièrement
mais bref c'est pas faire de promesses
dans devant cette année 2020 était
vraiment particulière je compte pour
chacun de nous espérons que 2021 soit
meilleure notamment dans tout ce qui est
pop culture avec tous les nombreux
reports les annulations et cetera on est
vraiment dans un moment un petit peu
unique en tout cas voilà mes meilleurs
voeux à chacun d'entre vous merci à tous
ceux qui me suivent encore jusqu'à
maintenant avoir plein de belles choses
à venir franchement j'ai toujours autant
passionné par youtube par les vidéos
donc j'espère que vos ma compagne aurait
encore longtemps
et puis voilà n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à laisser un petit pouce bleu un
petit commentaire et que le lionheart
soit avec vous c'était argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde et au revoir
[Musique]